ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually i
take it neat
but i will make an exception in the name
of health
last night i watched a movie with diane
and the girls
in which an orange fish is separated
from his father
the children were sniffling which i
believe to be due to the sad nature of
the film
i was wrong you need to take off those
layers rehydrate and go to the doctor
thank you for your concern i will be
fine
please turn the thermostat up to 90 and
leave me alone ron this isn't safe
i am a grown man i have had a cold
before
i need no help so if you don't
mind
that seems about right i'm just gonna
double check your form here
ron you redacted all the information i
answered some of them
for date of birth you wrote springtime
which is true
everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers
fine how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week
one that's it one drink one shelf
do you exercise yes lovemaking and
woodworking
do you have any history of mental
illness in your family i have an uncle
who does yoga
allergies cowardice and weak-willed men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic
and private okay i'm gonna go get your
doctor
he's a rude brash jerk you'll love them
these spindles are gorgeous and there's
almost a feeling of
musculature this transition the oak just
sort of
told me the shape before i even got to
the spoke shave this under bevel is a
great trick it really makes it feel
lighter while leaving you plenty of beef
to carve just really just a
modified danish line still you made it
your own this is as good a chair as i've
seen
i have nothing left to teach you oh
hurrah
thank you welcome to
you heard with perd i'm heard happily
the story of our guests today
is that they are from the department of
parks and recreation ben wyatt and tom
haverford what up perd
big fan me too perd what up
the thing about this first question is
i'd like to ask you about the harvest
festival
perd it's gonna be amazing carnival
rides games
sweden is even building a plus-size
roller coaster for some of pawnee's
obese thrill-seekers
you must be this wide to ride wow that's
gonna be a pretty big roller coaster
yep hey guys how'd it go
well there were some sticky moments
let's go to the videotape
ah look who hasn't had gay thoughts
who are you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine
i mean you know sometimes i feel like i
might need glasses
is there a bird in here i swear i keep
seeing a bird
in the studio maybe that's kind of like
happening to it he was fine until bird
started asking about the boy mayor's
stuff what's wrong with you you look
psychotic
i was 18 when i was elected mayor okay
so excuse me for that
cindy eckert had just turned me down for
senior prom do you know how that feels i
should call her
i should i no i shouldn't and i'm not
going to and i'm proud of myself for
that group
and then he talked about feeling up
cindy eckert for the first time for
about five minutes
and then the show ended as did our
careers and probably harvest fest
boom sadness that's the one hello mindy
my name is bee i'm from the good place
and welcome to your first day
in the afterlife what's up idiot sorry
i'm late babe
hey are you pregnant that's not possible
congrats
yeah so mindy look you mostly sucked but
then you did this one
good thing i mean i still think we
should get you they didn't but
neither did we a compromise was made the
neighborhood you were in now
by yourself you submitted a list of
things you wanted the good place
provided those things yeah and the bad
place made some modifications
we got you your favorite beer yeah but
it's always warm
on your jukebox you'll find every song
ever sung yeah by the eagles and
it's only the live versions also there's
some spoken word poetry from william
shatner
it's deeply terrible you get the idea
welcome to eternal mediocrity
welcome to the media place so what's up
what's your deal are you single what's
going on
i came from our bankruptcy brunch and
michael buble played but he ran a little
long
i love michael buble is a bankruptcy
brunch the best idea
sure let's not have brunch like animals
well um some of these expenditures are
questionable uh you filled the public
pools with bottled water
total body hydration what is this here
this massive
expenditure from public works ah yes
well
yes we purchased hbo for the whole town
i'm sorry you spent government money on
a tv subscription
it's not tv all right uh leslie's put
together a presentation for financial
recovery great
you may find it very informative let's
get started with our first slide
well well well
dude you broke michael no no this is
good he's having an existential crisis
it's a sort of anguish people go through
when they contemplate the
silent indifference of our empty
universe look
the good news is if he can work through
this it's the first step towards
understanding human ethics
and what if he can't well then he'll be
a lifeless shell of misery forever and
we're all doomed
okay i will be right back
gonna go grab some camus
hey buddy how you doing
can i get you a snack do you eat i can
never remember what do you eat
babies you want me to get you a big fat
baby what flavor baby oh
how about a cool ranch baby so i just
wanted to let you know
i will not be selling red to swag and
you can go tell your client he now has
100 problems is it jay-z no
but since you're not taking the deal i
should inform you that my client will be
moving on to plan b
opening his own store directly across
the street from yours across the street
what kind of store is it gonna be he's
calling it tommy's closet it's a
high-end secondhand clothing store where
parents can rent clothes for their teens
tweens and priests
as well as babies toddlers grown-ups and
olds but that's my idea and my name
so i guess only domino's is allowed to
sell pizza now it's called capitalism mr
haverford and you
are about to get a free lesson only this
free lesson
is going to cost you so it's not free
you're right that was confusing this
lesson will cost you
good day this sucks but i have to admit
it's a pretty baller move you sure this
isn't ditty
it is diddy i do it's not diddy
had to do it one last time before all
this goes away for good so what
are you offering me now nothing it's
over that was our last idea
good soon all your precious humans will
be gone
yeah it's too bad well congrats bud you
won
see you in a billion years when the
humans evolve again i'll be right back
at your throat you traitor
i mean yeah i know that's why i said
see in a billion years wait
i'm gonna do the evil speech now if you
want
since the dawn of time good and evil
have waged a furious battle
stemming for this feels stupid if you're
not gonna fight back how do you not have
another plan
you've always had another plan what's
wrong
okay fine gonna make me admit it
fighting you is the most fun i've ever
had i mean you know
you corkscrew your first eyeball and
you're like man i can't believe they're
paying me to do this
by the trillionth it's like i should
have just been a teacher
they claim that smoking is bad for you
but
is there any medical evidence to back
that up great point
so the swedus foundation has really
accomplished a lot recently
our healthcare outreach program has
reduced pink eye in the rural community
by 30 percent to 70
snooze you guys ever been foxhunting i
have my own foxes flown in from russia
we drug them pretty heavily so they
can't get very far in fact
mostly they just flop around on the
ground makes it easier to just walk up
and bow
stupid foxes it's deeply erotic
that sounds amazing we should go hunting
sometime i'd love to
i could bust out my ralph lauren fall
2010 collection
copped it in 2012. clearance rack wear
whatever you want
as long as it's not too bright or
reflective
you know i want you blending in to the
surroundings
how fast can you run i think that guy
wants to hunt me
knock knock knock no hey what's up
can i talk to you for a sec yeah sure
why not
hey derek yes mindy what can derek do
for you uh eleanor and i are gonna
talk for a bit so go into your
nethersphere that's
derek mindy has rebooted derek more than
151 million
times derek is now both a singular point
in space
and yet derek also contains space itself
the nexus of derek is without dimension
the moment of derek's creation and the
eventual heat death of the universe
are now inexorably the same ugh
you are so annoying
you